[Musique]
archives tiré de la campagne
présidentielle de 74 ou le tout premier
candidat écologiste casse le ronron
politique pour nous alerter sur des
dangers futur vous savez ce qui va se
passer eh bien nous allons bientôt
manquer de l'eau et c'est pourquoi je
bois devant vous un verre d'eau
précieuse puisque avant la fin du siècle
si nous continuons un tel débordement
elle manquera à lundi je vous dis au
revoir et j'espère vous revoir pour vous
expliquer notre projet global d'avenir
merci mes amis
[Musique]
rené dumont pionnier de l'écologie
politique
yannick jadot pourquoi nos sociétés ont
elles mis si longtemps à prendre cette
cause au sérieux parce que c'est
difficile parce que c'est difficile de
se projeter dans un avenir qui peut être
catastrophique si on n'agit pas parce
que c'est toujours difficile de changer
ses comportements parce qu'on a des
habitudes on a des conforts et surtout
si on a l'impression qu'au fond
si le voisin le fait parce que c'est
vraiment utile si la france le fait
parce que c'est vraiment grave et on
peut reporter comme ça les américains
qui dit si les chinois ne font pas
pourquoi nous le faire et que ça
s'inscrit dans le temps donc ce qu'il
faut arriver à faire aujourd'hui c'est à
démontrer que à la fois changer ses
comportements
c'est se faire du bien c'est nous faire
du bien collectivement mais
changer ses comportements ça suffit pas
c'est un quart de la réponse embraye
115% ce que tu es trois quarts de la
réponse sont les politiques publiques
donc on voit rené dumont dans l' alerte
évidemment aujourd'hui l'enjeu c'est de
prendre le pouvoir c'est de prendre le
pouvoir sortir du déni mais pour sortir
du déni il faut créer d'entousiasme à la
fois répondent concrètement dire le
chemin et dire que tout le monde sera
sur ce chemin là que ça se fera d'abord
bénéfice des des plus fragiles victime
de du dérèglement climatique victimes de
la pollution de l'air victimes de la
malbouffe et que ça se fera d'abord à
leurs bénéfices et non pas à leur
détriment
[Musique]
rené dumont le premier candidat
écologiste qui a fait un un peu plus de
voix que jean marie le pen d'ailleurs à
cette élection mais qui n'a pas été
beaucoup entendu à l'époque c'est
dommage
oui enfin c'est dommage la réalité c'est
que c'est le modèle économique
qui a été développée plus tard qui est
le
vrai modèle qui tuent notre planète
c'est le modèle ultra libéral c'est le
modèle fondé sur le libre échange sur le
moins disant social sur
l'utilisation le pillage en fait de la
planète c'est ça auquel il faut mettre
fin pour pouvoir retrouver
pour pouvoir défendre l'environnement
véritablement la pollution enregistrée
est comme moi non mais la pollution
existait mais je vais tout nous dit là
d'ailleurs depuis cette période là que
c'est par la technologie aussi qu'on
arrive à résoudre les problèmes qui sont
la conséquence de l'activité humaine
vous voyez c'est c'est grâce aux progrès
en fait qu'on arrive à faire en sorte
que
les industries polluantes moins que le
nucléaire pollue moins que c'est grâce
par exemple aux usines de désalinisation
de l'eau que l'on peut demain on règle
déjà mais on réglera encore plus demain
le manque d'eau dans le monde parce
qu'il avait raison il ya des endroits
qui manquent d'eau aujourd'hui au moment
où nous nous parlons et donc moi je
crois beaucoup progrès je veux dire je
pense pas que les choses soient fixés
que l'on de faille faire indéfiniment
siècle après siècle avec les éléments
technologiques que nous avons non on va
trouver on découvre des choses tous les
jours pour pouvoir améliorer la
situation mais il n'en demeure pas moins
que le modèle économique lui s'ils
continuent si on continue à le choisir
au lieu du localisme au lieu de la
proximité eh bien on finira par mal
vivre ses mains tellement la planète qui
souffrent sont les hommes qui souffrent
d'un ace vous n'êtes pas écologiste
canal historique on a bien compris les
écoutant jean-marie le pen disait parler
de la l'écologie comme la nouvelle
religion des bobos gogos s'est longtemps
été une expression en partie oui bon non
mais c'est pas ça non moi je suis plutôt
je suis plutôt attaché à ces
problématiques écologistes mais je ne
cessais de les regarder par laure par le
vrai bout de la lorgnette pas par le
mauvais bout de la lorgnette oui
[Musique]
c'était dans les spots de la campagne
officielle rené dumont le premier
candidat écolo qui prêchait assez
largement dans le désert les communistes
ont mis longtemps à se réveiller sur la
question d'écologie non
écoutez vous savez pour préparer cette
élection présidentielle j'ai ressorti
des archives des précédentes élections
présidentielles où nous avions présenté
des candidats et j'ai ressorti un quatre
pages qui avait publié robert hue dans
la campagne de 95
sur l'enjeu environnemental et
écologique et le besoin de sortir d'un
système économique qui
épuise autant les hommes que la planète
et nos ressources naturelles nous avions
à l'époque mis l'accent sur le besoin de
développer les réseaux ferrés le
transport des marchandises de lutter
contre la pollution de l'air le
réchauffement climatique c'était écrit
noir sur blanc et donc
c'était il ya plus de 20 ans et donc
nous portions déjà l'exigence de changer
de système économique et des logiques de
profit qui épuise la planète et les
hommes parce que vous savez le
capitalisme vert que défend certains
écologistes ça ne marche pas le problème
c'est pas la couleur c'est le
capitalisme et nous c'est à ça qu'on
s'attaque
[Musique]
rené dumont premier candidat écologiste
à l'élection présidentielle
vous en avez le souvenir jean lassalle
pas fait demain et je trouve que c'est
une
des images cultes de l'hymne à ce jeu
les vus et revus à plusieurs reprises
permettez moi de me distinguer toutefois
un peu de lui parce que bien sûr je je
je vois son caractère visionnaire mais
je n'ai jamais eu par rapport à ça un
caractère aussi
définitif est désespérée peut-être parce
que j'avais lu la bible comme j'ai lu le
capital
et dans la bible
est un passage où il est question du
grenelle et le guen là ça veut dire la
bande verte à l'anglais je crois moi qui
n'ai jamais fais engueuler mais plutôt
d'espagne âge qu'on vous l'avez rappelé
il semblerait que le guen là à cette
époque là était une bande ou des
cavaliers
se déplacer à bride abattue dans des
nuages de poussière je trouve que
aujourd'hui on manque peut être un peu
trop de climatologues jamais suivi un
certain nombre pour démontrer que sur
des périodes courtes les climats en
beaucoup le climat a beaucoup changé
mais moins au lieu de me suicider ou de
m dell peur un tel stress dans la vie
demande déjà assez
préoccupés par tous je préférerais qu'on
met 1 5% à la recherche fondamentale la
recherche appliquée pour trouver au plus
vite l'énergie de demain je crois
qu'elle sera solaire comme le forum
comme le laboratoire de forum à
perpignan ou alors l'énergie des marées
mélenchon qui est le candidat le plus
expérimenté avec moi en parle lui aussi
vous imaginez que nous avons 11 millions
de kilomètres carrés grâce
à nos cotes
la chine ne fait que 8 millions de
kilomètres carrés est ce que vous voyez
l'espace que nous avons pour essayer de
voir ce fait pas quelque chose entre
avec la différence thermique qu'il
existe entre la surface des flots et
celle qui lie à 2000 mètres de saut je
veux que la france se dote et soit la
première à trouver l'énergie de demain
totalement renouvalables si je vous ai
bien entendu jean lassalle vous vous
contester l'idée que la terre se
réchauffe sous l'effet des activités
humaines en tout cas vous partager
l'idée qu'il y a des cycles de
réchauffement et de refroidissement qui
sont indépendants de de l'activité
humaine sur la terre
écoutez je ne peux pas contester parce
que je ne suis pas assez
je vois un chevronné en la matière pour
ça il y à dos cadets singh et les images
que vous montrez
le faut je suis président des
populations des montagnes du monde je
vois à travers les montagnes
effectivement ne serait-ce que les
glaciers mais bien d'autres choses
changer mais en tout cas si tel est le
cas on se trompe totalement d'adressent
en accusant les hommes et les femmes y
sont obligés de se servir de leurs
moteurs diesel dans leurs campagnes
parce qu'ils n'ont pas le choix
[Musique]
alerte qui a mis du temps beaucoup de
temps à être prise au sérieux valérie
pécresse oui alors j'appartiens comme
vous savez à une filiation où on s'est
beaucoup préoccuper d'écologie que ce
soit jacques chirac avec le discours de
johannesburg que ce soit nicolas sarkozy
avec le grenelle de l'environnement moi
cette préoccupation écologique
elle est très forte en moi comme
ministre de la recherche j'ai fait
tranché l'académie des sciences sur
l'existence dû réchauffement climatique
et sur la responsabilité de l'homme dans
ce réchauffement à l'époque vous savez
claude allègre aller sur les plateaux et
désespéré les climatologues en disant
que le réchauffement climatique
n'existait pas et le fonctionnement
médiatique étant ce qu'il est sur les
plateaux il y avait 1 pour 1 contre et
un journaliste au milieu qui ne
prenaient en général pas partie donc les
climatologues m'avait saisi en disant
fait rétabli c'est la vérité et donc
j'ai fait tranché l'académie des
sciences c'était une des dernières
académie qui s'était pas prononcée
encore sur le sujet alors cette urgence
climatique elle nous oblige est l'un des
grands enjeux du prochain mandat c'est
celui que qui est décrit dans votre dans
votre dans votre petit extrait c'est
celui de la gestion de l'eau qui va
devenir une question très dramatique
avec le réchauffement nous avons besoin
de respecter les engagements de la
conférence de paris aujourd'hui la
france n'en respecte aucun donc nous
devons nous mettre dans une trajectoire
qui nous amènera au zéro carbone 2050
nous devons nous mettre dans une
trajectoire qui préservera les
ressources de la planète mais ma
conviction c'est que l'écologie c'est
pas une idéologie l'écologie c'est des
résultats concrets c'est des résultats
en termes de baisse de pollution c'est
des résultats en termes d'énergies
propres et des résultats en termes de
sobriété de consommation s'est inventé
une nouvelle croissance qui sera sobre
parce que moi je ne crois pas à la
décroissance pas dans un pays avec des
difficultés sociales aussi forte que la
france nous avons besoin de ne pas
opposer l'écologie à l'économie mais
c'est toute l'économie qu'il faut
redéfinir
reconstruire réinventer
[Musique]
nathalie arthaud est ce que la nature
l'environnement le bien-être animal est
ce que ça fait partie de vos combats ou
est-ce que ça vous paraît secondaire
bien sûr que ça fait partie de mes
combats alors là c'est une archive de 74
vous prenez du monde voilà tu y étais
quand voilà les habits du candidat écolo
même temps que la première candidature
de voile à 74 alors vous voyez souvent
nous on nous accuse de
de dire et de répéter le même discours
depuis 30 ans depuis 40 ans sophie cinq
ans mais je vois que lui c'est pareil
les écologistes ils sont face à la même
à la même situation en fait 20 voiliers
se voit là il vient parce que parce que
ce système capitaliste ans la réalité
c'est qu'ils exploitent les hommes
autant qu'ils exploitent la nature et
ils les exploitent jusqu'à leur extrême
limite jusqu'à les détruire
moi c'est ce qui me frappe dans cette
dans ce système là tout est bon pour
faire du fric tout alors bon on a vu le
scandale des ehpad vous avez vu même
même les derniers jours de notre vie
servent à faire du fric pour certains
mais la nature c'est pareil donc pour
moi c'est le même combat tout ça on peut
pas accepter que il y ait une minorité
capitaliste qui ne jurent que par leur
fric et après moi le déluge mais c'est
ça qui se passe c'est ces grandes
multinationales total mais dans
l'agroalimentaire c'est la même chose et
et moi ce que je ce que ce que j'ai
quand même envie de dire aujourd'hui
c'est que on leur fait confiance à eux à
ceux qui ont pollué à ceux qui ont
détruit la planète on leur fait
confiance pour que pour faire la
transition énergétique pour que demain
en fait enfin on respecte les ressources
naturelles on leur fait confiance mais
mais mais mais comment leur faire
confiance ce n'est pas possible ce n'est
pas possible alors moi oui je prétend
d'ailleurs dans cette campagne à voir le
programme le plus conséquent en matière
écologique pourquoi parce que je suis
pour l'expropriation de ses grandes
multinationales et pour qu'on les prenne
en main de façon collective et que pour
qu'on les fasse fonctionner non
seulement pour qu'elles répondent
d'abord aux besoins vitaux un des femmes
et des hommes et pas aux caprices de
quelques riches mais aussi pour qu elles
pour qu'elles puissent répond pour
qu'elle puisse préserver la planète pour
qu'on prenne en considération
effectivement et bien
la limitation un de ces de ses
ressources naturelles
[Musique]
rené dumont j'ai tellement ri candidat
écolo qui prend un peu de son temps de
d'antenne pour voir ce verre d'eau il
poil regardez nous sommes en 2022 on en
parle il a eu raison mais avant tout le
monde et mais on n'entendait pas il ya
50 ans non non non non non pas du tout
pourquoi moi je sais que j'ai repris
cette bataille de l'eau parce que je
pense que c'est le prochain ça bien là
ça va être la grosse question vous
pouvez vous passer tous au dos donc je
vais pas vous faire mes arguments sur le
sujet mais à l'époque non entendez par
la gauche était dominée par le
productivisme idéologie qui allait avec
si vous voulez on allait développer les
forces productives et on allait les
développer tellement bien qu'ils
auraient pour tout le monde et donc tout
irait bien et tout irait mieux et on
était tous là dedans et on écoutait pas
et quand françois mitterrand par exemple
fait un éditorial dans le journal du ps
les poches pour s'appeler l'unité alors
il a fait un truc que l'oiseau qui
s'étouffe dans l'air le poisson qui se
noie dans la rivière mais tout éclater
de rire les gens autour de moi des mais
qu'est ce qu'ils racontent qu'ils aient
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc les
oiseaux qui s'asphyxie dans l'herbe mais
pis quoi encore non il y avait zéro
tolérance zéro écoute et quand il ya eu
le
le club de rome alors quand il ya eu un
club qui s'est fait et en réaction des
intellectuels comme gb autres ont fait
l'an zéro bon il proposait de réduire
justement le niveau 2 delà du
productivisme il faut voir ce qu'on
disait à leur sujet qu'on de l'angoissé
des suppôts du capitalisme ils veulent
augmenter le chômage et faire peur aux
travailleurs enfin le discours était
complètement stéréotypé bloqué paralysé
et il a fallu que je me trouve moi
confronté à l'absurdité de ce qu'on
racontait que je me rende compte que au
fond les l'écologie politique
présentait la question du collectivisme
sous l'angle qui m'intéressait c'est à
dire les biens communs l'humanité comme
une seule espèce animale bon et que tout
d'un coup je fasse le lien entre ça et
mon fondamental qui est la philosophie
humaniste et révolutionnaire 89 droits
de l'homme pour que je comprenne que
tous à stenay et que c'est ce qu'on
racontait qui tenait pas avec bon cette
vision absolument c'est du mauvais
prométhéen c'est prométhée exalté parce
que moi tout réglé par en produisant
produisant et en prélevant un quart en
marche on l'avait lu que comme ça
pourtant marx est le premier à dire le
capitalisme épuise l'homme et la nature
mais ça nous intéressait pas à l'époque
voulait pas voir ça
[Musique]
rené dumont le premier candidat écolo il
avait raison non il avait raison et pas
raison à la fois mais il avait raison et
j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour les gens
de conviction
lui aussi on aurait pu dire qu'il était
don quichotte mais on s'aime toujours
des petites graines qui évolue la preuve
et il a raison c'est un d un des défis
majeurs
simplement on le prend par le mauvais
sens à mon avis voilà c'est à dire que
on se donne bonne conscience alors que
là le seul moyen est ce ce que je
propose de d'éviter l'explorer chauffe
mans climatique et le désert des océans
j'ai fait un rapport là dessus c'est de
mettre fin à la mondialisation inhumaine
c'est à dire de mettre des barrières
douanières de couper avec la chine qui
est en train de de faire exploser la
planète à chaque fois qu'on consomme
allemand ou chinois
on participe du gaz à effet de serre
c'est que n'ont pas compris nos écolos
[Musique]
rené dumont le candidat écolo qui n'a
pas été prise au sérieux des nox est
vrai pas même par les grands partis de
gauche non bien sûr mais moi j'avais 14
ans je me souviens vraiment de cette
scène alors on avait une télé noir et
blanc enfin je me souviens très bien de
cette scène et et pour moi ça a été le
début aussi d'une prise de conscience je
suis pas rentré juste pas devenu écolo
à ce moment là je me suis pas intéressé
aux formations verte qui commençait à a
voilà exister dans le pays mais en
revanche il y avait du côté du ps eu du
côté de cette deuxième gauche beaucoup
de femmes et d'hommes je pense aussi à
huguette bouchardeau je pense d'une
certaine façon à michel rocard aussi qui
portait déjà ces questions d'écologie
alors ce n'était pas tellement sur l'eau
c'est vrai que lui rené dumont a été le
premier à le prendre sur cet angle là la
gauche et y compris cette deuxième
gauche le prenait plutôt sous l'angle du
développement et moi j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser vraiment à ce moment là
aussi à la politique et aux idées
sociales socialistes et écologistes mais
ça a été pour moi vraiment un
oui une alerte quelque chose qui à ce
moment là m'a ouvert vraiment sur cette
question de l'écologie et je m'en
souviens encore j'avais 14 ans
[Musique]
y passer pour un hurluberlu à l'époque
mais il n'avait pas tort il a fait un
coup absolument magnifique je m'en
souviens très bien parce que j'étais
passionné de politique à l'époque et
donc je suivais ça avec avec avec
passion je suivais tous les débats
politiques il y avait dix cars
mitterrand etc et tous les autres ça
vous a pas ancré dans l'écologie pour
attendre non pas du tout pas du tout
d'ailleurs il se trompait il disait
avant la fin du siècle on est vingt ans
après le siècle et on ne manque pas
d'eau et personne ne manque d'eau alors
qu'il y ait des problèmes écologiques
qu'il y ait un réchauffement climatique
très bien mais je vous dire très mal
mais en tout cas il se trompait dans
l'hôtellerie diction de quelques
décennies seulement commandes de
quelques décès mais vous n'en savez rien
vous n'en savez rien moi je ne pense pas
qu'on manquera d'eau
je pense je crois je crois à deux choses
je crois à l'adaptabilité
infinie de la de l'espèce humaine et je
crois au génie humain qui va trouver des
solutions techniques comme il a toujours
trouvé comme il a toujours trouvé pour
se sortir des situations qui paraissent
des impasses donc si vous voulez jouer
ça je crois profondément maintenant
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il n'y aura pas
de difficultés de crise voyez de
catastrophe mais
moi je pense si vous voulez que la
catastrophe qui menace la france ce
n'est pas une catastrophe écologique
mais c'est une catastrophe démographique
et c'est un remplacement de population
et un remplacement de civilisations sur
notre sol je pense que en 2050 la
population française sera à majorité
musulmane voire africaine et que donc ça
ne sera plus la france et que c'est pour
cela que je me suis présenté à la
président à l'élection présidentielle et
c'est pour cela que je me bats pour
empêcher cela voyez chacun à ces
catastrophes ces prédictions moi c'est
la catastrophe que je vois venir est qui
et qui me taraude le plus parce que je
suis attachée d'abord à la france
[Musique]